the master of dark fairy tales the one
and only you know him and love them
easily one of the nicest guys I know
thank you my friends I'll be here
tomorrow too so greedy MOU you are
making a grand return to the genre that
you really helped to find why is it the
right time for you to return to war well
I wanted to make a movie that was able
to blend two sides of my personality
after I did Mamie Mamie was such a tough
experience that I said you know I'm
going to do the more painterly sort of
beautiful and creepy things and my
Spanish language films and I'm gonna do
the big pop sort of fault
fawn movies in English and then after
having such a great experience with
legendary on Pacific Rim
I had such a blast with them that they
came back the universal have acquired a
project that was very personal to me
Donna Langley loved it it was called the
crimson peak and thank you and it's a
Gothic romance and it was very delicate
I thought no I'm gonna just produce it I
cannot resist but when they did I said
let's do it let's let's do it the way
you want it
they said it's not rated as incredible
beauty but is also very violent they
said that's okay
okay so I thought it was a perfect way
to return to the genre the movie is a
fusion of that is incredibly gorgeous I
urge you guys to visit the graphic
gallery at the legendary booth and to do
both the crimson peak experience and the
Pacific Rim oculus rift which is [ __ ]
awesome
[ __ ]
so do you have anything that you would
like to share with hall age yeah yeah
you know it's militia legendary battles
people say we're good a little Glynn's
and then [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] lands in
your back come out and bombard your
family this is really small
this really is we are a year and a half
from releasing the movie but I
nevertheless wanted to reveal for the
first time a little bit of the look of
the film the is the first time you're
gonna see not on not on Twitter not on
Pinterest photos of the actual cast in
wardrobe and just to get a sense of how
the movie is gorgeous today and I'd lost
Federation's before next year we're
gonna come back you will get me but
you'll get some [ __ ] hidden stone I
hope we have the whole cast is an
amazing the best cast I've ever had
that's my special effects in this movie
those actors and I must tell you girls
some hero stone sadly for me is the
nicest [ __ ] guy on earth it used to
be in the past that you were either nice
or you were good looking at an [ __ ]
that has been gone down because you know
what did a chubby guy have gone for them
before this you were Sympatico you made
jokes now this guy breaks everything so
at any rate I hope you enjoyed the look
of this huh we'll talk a little bit more
about it and what the themes are on it
first tiny loop you're gonna have a way
look of Korean Zombie the colors are
amazing they're beautiful it's gorgeous
it's it's it's you're a painter you're a
painter well this is a movie that comes
very close to being and living paintings
it's beautifully colored color-coded
the labor of love of building an entire
Victorian mansion three stories high in
a stage with working elevators working
bathrooms not all parts of the bathroom
don't worry but who roams a full library
it was truly truly a labor of love we
spend the best part of a year designing
it then building it to the all to the
ultimate detail everything you see was
built for the film and-and-and what I
wanted was the freedom to tackle a great
adult story for a female lead you know I
loved very strong and I think and I
think that it's great when the female
lead is introduced to a normal romantic
story but then you say you know what let
us leave let us see her live past all
that past the guy getting getting the
guy no gay [ __ ] that [ __ ] let us see her
become her own person and and and that
journey is very much detailed on crimson
peak we do what is done in Gothic
romance we have the thriller aspect of
it we have the romance aspect of it
beautiful moments and very brutal very
brutal moments and we have scary ghosts
but I think scarier people than ghosts
so you know I think it's a beautiful
adult confection and I hope you enjoyed
that I know you guys didn't do any time
for Q&A but I love the [ __ ] your name
so I'm gonna I'm gonna do two questions
for the audience if you don't mind mind
you guys need to tell us what you think
of this alright here we go number one
I mean we're with legendary which is the
coolest studio on earth Universal which
is the Monster House I have two things
to ask from you and you need to react
all right number one Hellboy 3
yeah they're listening there listen not
at the mountains of madness now now it's
over
thank you very much
you